Hi, I'm Jessica with TopTenREVIEWS.
Landing that job is more important than ever.
So, let's go over two different scenarios...
...so you can find the best interviewing skills to ace that interview.
In this scenario, our interviewee, Kyle,...
...doesn't start off his interview on the right step because he's late.
Kyle did not dress appropriately for his interview.
A hat, a shirt unbuttoned;...
...he has a sloppy look that can transition from sloppy look to sloppy work.
Kyle is talking too much about something the interviewer didn't even ask him about,...
...as he goes on and on.
The interviewer is bored and unimpressed.
Make sure to be concise and answer questions directly.
He has bad posture and Kyle isn't making eye contact with the interviewer either.
Kyle didn't come ready with any materials like a resume or a paper to take notes.
Don't chew gum.
If you need good breath, go for a breath mint instead.
And last but not least, Kyle had bad hygiene.
By the look on that interviewer's face, I'd say he didn't get the job.
Obviously, doing an interview like Kyle's won't get you anywhere.
You should also remember to never be cocky or appear desperate to get that job.
And you shouldn't talk too much or use jargon...
...and use inappropriate language during an interview.